monsieur stéphane ravier avait trois
minutes seulement
monsieur le président madame le premier
ministre mes chers collègues
dans la promesse d'un gouvernement très
resserré à la nomination de 41 membres
en passant par le maintien voire la
promotion des ministres en charge de la
france en grand en grand en sauvagement
en grand remplacement en grand des
classements et en grand enfermement je
laissais pas vous mes chers collègues
mais moi j'ai la douloureuse sensation
de vivre un jour sans fin tant ce
gouvernement born 2 aurait pu s'appeler
castex 4 ou encore edouard philippe 6 ce
retour permanent en arrière aurait pu
être une cure de jouvence s'il ne
s'agissait pas d'une nouvelle cure de
souffrance vous voulez madame le premier
ministre renouveau démocratique sans
vote de confiance du parlement sans
ministère des relations avec l eau que
les collectivités territoriales et en
conservant un garde des sceaux ministre
du laxisme judiciaire et du grand ans
sauvagement mis en examen par la cour de
justice de la république vous choisissez
de reconduire à son poste les ministres
du grand remplacement de l'intérieur
désormais connu comme celui du mensonge
et de l'humiliation de notre pays suite
au désastre des razzias et de l'hyper
violence commise au stade de
l'anti-france vous voulez lutter contre
séparatisme de l'islam et vous nommé
ministre de la ville et du logement un
maire favorable au droit de vote des
étrangers à la multiplication des
mosquées et à leur financement public
vous prétendez un kit vous inquiétez du
pouvoir d'achat des français tout en
conservant les ministres du grand
effondrement économique et du grand
déclassement social qui a accru la dette
publique de 600 milliards d'euros en
cinq ans seuls la moitié de cette somme
de ce gouffre étant imputable à la crise
qu vide
l'ancien ministre de la santé le
ministre de tous les enfermements
physique comme démocratique largement
visés par la justice administrative pour
impréparation et mensonges durant la
première vague coded est devenu le porte
parole du gouvernement mais quel symbole
pour lui succéder à la santé vous avez
choisi de nommer ministre pro masque
provoque pro passe vaccinaux lattre et
déjà honni des professionnels de santé
car adeptes du tri des patients en
réponse à l'engorgement des urgences
plutôt l'intégration des migrants que la
réintégration des soignants vous voulez
plus d'écologie sans parler de localisme
la ruralité à son secrétariat d'état
mais elle n'a pas en revanche les moyens
humains et financiers dont bénéficie la
politique de la ville cache sexe on le
sait de la politique d'immigration avec
ses milliards d'euros et que dire du
ministre de l'éducation plutôt de la
rééducation et du vivre ensemble
obligatoires pape diouf autisme de la
déconstruction de notre identité humaine
et nationales dont la nomination a été
saluée or le grand timonier de l'islamo
gauchisme qu'est jean luc mélenchon
quant à la ministre la culture ou de la
des cultures elle conseillait déjà le
président quand il déclarait qu'il n'y
avait pas de culture française il n'y a
même pas de ministère de la famille à
l'heure où les démographes annoncent que
les français seront minoritaires chez
eux dans quelques dizaines d'années dans
le contexte d'hyper crise que nous
traversons vous proposer de la
continuité vous rajoutez donc de la
crise à toutes les crises manifestement
mes chers collègues à travers la
composition de son gouvernement force
est de constater qu'il n'ya pas que les
non vaccinés emmanuel macron décidé
d'emmerdés c'est désormais l'ensemble
des français je serai là quand à moi
pour m'y opposer je veux croire que je
ne serai pas le seul
[Musique]